long before bitcoin there was a dot-com
company called e-gold that was started
in 1996 an entire 13 years before
bitcoin was released and the idea was
simple take on central bank's head first
by creating an encrypted anonymous
digital currency that was based on a
fixed supply of 71 million dollars worth
of gold where users can make instant
transfers of value to other eagle
accounts and transactions as small as 1
10 000 of a gram of gold that way you
couldn't just print more money unlike
the us dollar the money could be divided
down way smaller than the us dollar and
the system was somewhat decentralized
having servers in iceland dubai and all
over the world in other words eagle was
the precursor to bitcoin and it took off
by the year 2000 eagle went hyperbolic
peter thiel co-founder of paypal at the
time meets the founders of eagle on a
beach in angola and their eyes were set
on revolution and you know
we're beginning the revolution against
central banks on the beach in anguilla
we're going to make paypal interoperable
with e-gold and we're going to blow up
all the central banks starting right now
by 2004 there were over 1 million eagle
accounts making it the first digital
currency ever to gain widespread
adoption at its peak in 2006 e-gold was
processing more than 2 billion dollars
worth of transactions with just 71
million dollars of eagle in circulation
but there was a problem eagle was a
corporation a corporation formed on the
caribbean island of nevis one of the
world's most secretive tax havens
nonetheless but their corporate officers
weren't anonymous they were based in
south florida
shortly after peter 2 met the founders
on a fateful day on a beach in angola
fraud floods the system criminals were
using eagle to accept payment from their
victims to fuel their scams and policy
schemes hackers were compromising eagle
accounts and when the victims went to
the government to complain the net
bureaucrats didn't understand the
difference between ego the company and
the actual criminals to them eagles and
the criminals were one and the same and
eagle became the scapegoats you know
three months later there was sort of a
lot of fraud we disconnected e-gold you
know they they they sued me for liable
it's all sort of an adversarial
relationship we we settled you know we
always you never negotiate with
terrorists except every specific
instance we gave them some money made
them go away um that was 2002.
fast forward to 2007 and the u.s
treasury in conjunction with the
department of justice indebted eagles
for money laundering and illegal money
transmitting under everyone's favorite
acts the patriot act
a year later ego pled guilty to all
charges but you fast forward to 2008 and
you know the people sort of got arrested
and i think they didn't go to jail but
they agreed to just not do this anymore
to shut down the company and uh and and
go away the government had just
successfully shut down the first real
threat to their monopoly on money and
eagle was no more
just five short months later as the
world was melting down the economy was
formally and officially declared in
recession as people were questioning the
very structure of the financial system i
don't think anyone really expected a
bank as big as movement to uh you know
be in a position that it's in now a
little old white paper was released the
title bitcoin a peer-to-peer electronic
cash system the author it wasn't a
company incorporated in some secrecy
haven this time no the author chose to
be anonymous going by the name of
satoshi nakamoto
and peter thiel's theory it was that
satoshi was on that beach in anguilla
and he saw e-gold and um and bitcoin was
the answer to e-gold and satoshi learned
that you had to be anonymous and you had
to not have a comp even a company was
even a company even a corporate form was
too governmentally linked and gave the
government too many hooks and so you had
to have an algorithm that was not a
corporation and you had a per how to
have a person who is completely unknown
and so it's even the same it's a
computer word and a money word bitcoin
eagle
but that's what i think the thing is
this is just one theory on the identity
of satoshi and 13 years later it seems
like we're nowhere closer to answering
this question who created bitcoin
newsweek reports that he is the
mastermind behind bitcoin this is the
enduring mystery of satoshi nakamoto
[Applause]
the enduring mystery of satoshi nakamoto
[Music]
and if you want a free 15
seriously a free 15
all you have to do is pause the video
and sign up for cash app using referral
code youtube with the link below and
cash app will literally give you 15 to
get you started if you don't know cash
up is an extremely popular app that is
known for democratizing banking by being
the easiest way to send and receive
money for your friends family and
customers instantly from the app for
free and now cash app is also
democratizing crypto yes you can now buy
bitcoin within cash app with as little
as one dollar and not only that you can
also buy stocks within the app too and
cash app comes with a ton of other great
features that really does make it the
easiest way to send spend bank and
invest with cash app you can receive
your paychecks up to two days early atm
use is free too as long as you have 300
coming into your account each month and
you can even get a customizable fee-free
debit card that you can use to earn
instant discounts on everyday spending
cash app will laser at your custom
design on the card and mail it straight
to your door and cash app is available
to anyone over 13 years old you just
won't have access to their investing
services if you're under 18. so use code
youtube for 15 by pausing the video and
signing up for cash app at cash dot app
slash download with the link below
that's cash dot app slash download using
referral code youtube with the link
below thanks to cash out for sponsoring
this video
[Music]
suspect won the government
[Applause]
in 1996 over a decade before the
existence of bitcoin the nsa published a
paper titled how to make a mint the
cryptography of anonymous electronic
cash
in it nsa researchers outlined a system
very much like bitcoin where financial
transactions are secured via
cryptography and made possible via a
decentralized network that way your
digital money could have privacy
protection against double spending and
protection against denial of service
eerily similar to a blockchain 13 years
later the bitcoin white paper was
released and the cryptographic algorithm
bitcoin uses to secure its transactions
the shot 256 algorithm
and the creator of the algorithm none
other than the nsa
think about it as the government
wouldn't it be nice if you had a clean
perfect immutable database that
displayed everyone's transactions on a
public ledger while giving everyone the
illusion of privacy if you have such a
tool as long as you can connect a wallet
address to a person which is not that
hard to do evading taxes would be a
thing of the past laundering money would
be a thing of the past what does that
mean as the ruling class you could get a
perfect birth eye view of where money is
flowing through the entire economy in
fact this tool would be a dream come
true for agencies like the fbi and
that's exactly what bitcoin has turned
out to be what people need to recognize
is that bitcoin is the greatest thing to
happen to the fbi quite literally the
best form of ransom payment for federal
agents after all this wouldn't be the
first time the government invented such
a powerful technology the internet came
from the arpanet projects which was
directly funded by the government the
technology behind the tour network for
the dark web called onion routing was
developed in the mid-1990s by the u.s
naval research laboratory
so the chances of the creator of bitcoin
being the us government itself is
definitely above zero
but there are a few holes in this theory
for a project of the scale it would be
very difficult to keep it completely
under wraps eventually someone would
have probably let it slip
but then again there have been plenty of
government projects successfully kept
under rouse for years or even decades
before the truth came out
area 51 has been at the center of some
of this country's most closely guarded
secrets but only now has the government
officially acknowledged the existence of
area 51 in nevada
for a government project the government
seems to be resisting it pretty hard
even suggesting we create a central bank
digital currency to combat the new
competition of crypto i don't think that
bitcoin i've said this before is widely
used as a transaction mechanism it's an
extremely inefficient way of
conducting transactions they see the
temptation to print money is the
greatest temptation in the whole world
and it's the temptation that the us
government has full control over right
now you can't print more bitcoins the
supply is fixed so i don't see the
government releasing a technology that
would take that power away anytime soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
just a few months after the bitcoin
white paper was published the first
bitcoins to ever exist were mined by
satoshi himself just a few days later
the first bitcoin transaction took place
on january 11 2009 and then satoshi
started mining a lot of bitcoins during
this period satoshi would occasionally
post on a forum called bitcointalk.org
to communicate with the community he
ended up with over 1.1 million bitcoins
and more than 145 wallets in july 2010
that was worth around 99 000
today it's worth around 50 billion
dollars depending on where the price is
making him the 29th richest person alive
today right below people like the koch
family and jeff bezos's ex-wife
mackenzie scott
but satoshi never stuck around on
december 12 2010 he posted a message
about adding denial of service controls
to bitcoin he logged on again on
december 13th probably to read the
replies to his post then he logged off
and just like that he was never heard
from again
but then 2014 rolls around and the
magazine newsweek publishes a high
profile article titled the face behind
bitcoin claiming to have identified who
satoshi was once and for all
and just like that the world was
introduced to dorian nakamoto a
japanese-american man living in
california whose birth name was satoshi
nakamoto what was interesting was that
aside from his birth name he seemed like
a prime suspect he was trained as a
physicist at cal poly he worked as a
systems engineer on classified defense
projects and he worked as a computer
engineer for tech and financial
companies he was laid off twice in the
early 90s which led him to becoming a
libertarian encouraging his daughter to
start her own business quotes not under
the government's thumb end quotes and to
top it all off when asked about bitcoin
during a brief in-person interview with
the journalist behind the article
nakamoto had apparently led a slip that
he was indeed the inventor of bitcoin
saying that quote i am no longer
involved in that and i cannot discuss it
it's been turned over to other people
they were in charge of it now i no
longer have any connection end quotes
and just like that nakamoto's life was
turned upside down reporters were camped
near his house they would chase him by
car and nakamoto proceeded to deny all
claims that he was the inventor of
bitcoin even hosting a reddit ama to
discuss it he said he thought the
reporter was referring to another
project he worked on with one of his
previous jobs later that same day the
real satoshi nakamoto logged on for the
first time in five years to post this
message quote i am not dorian nakamoto
end quote
the case seemed to be solved dorian
nakamoto was not the inventor of bitcoin
after all but then six months after that
message the same account that posted
that said that the account had been
hacked was the denial fake did the
inventor of bitcoin really use his own
birth name or was the story about to get
a lot crazier
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
suspect three how finny
[Applause]
meet hal finney hal finney was a game
developer for some classic games from
the late 70s to early 80s
then his career took a suspicious turn
when he became a cryptographer for the
pgp corporation a company that sold a
cryptographic software called pretty
good privacy pgp was used for signing
encrypting and decrypting text emails
files and more to make emails more
secure he held a successful competition
to break the encryption netscape used in
2004 he created the first reusable proof
of work system long before bitcoin so
needless to say how finney was a
cryptographic expert even aligning
himself with the cypherpunk movement
an online community of people who
advocate for strong cryptography and
privacy tech for social and political
reasons he once said quote the computer
can be used as a tool to liberate and
protect people rather than to control
them end quotes
and by the time bitcoin was up and
running how finney receives the first
ever bitcoin transaction if he wasn't
the creator of bitcoin i think it's safe
to assume that he was probably in
contact with whoever it was but perhaps
the strangest coincidence hal finney's
address he lived just a few blocks away
from dorian nakamoto for 10 years
later during the same year bitcoin
launched hal finney's life takes a
tragic turn he gets diagnosed with als
and by 2013 he becomes essentially
paralyzed an extortionist demands an
extortion fee of a thousand bitcoins and
ends up swatting finney's home
by august 2014 hal halifani passes away
from complications of als taking any
connection he had with satoshi to the
grave his body was crowd preserved
literally frozen in store to be
hopefully reanimated in the future at
the alcor life extension foundation in
arizona
if he's ever successfully brought back
to life maybe we'll find out the
[Applause]
for truth back
[Applause]
and then there's adam beck who's now the
ceo of blockstream a company that makes
infrastructure tech that expands the
capability of bitcoin like allowing you
to connect to bitcoin without an
internet connection but before all of
this back when the bitcoin white paper
was first released adam black was one of
the references made in the white paper
not only did adam black have the
expertise and the motivation to make
something like bitcoin but the
circumstantial evidence fits adam have
been interested in creating something
like bitcoin since 1998's in fact he had
over 700 published posts on the
cypherpunk forum and yet when the
bitcoin whitepaper was released he
showed absolutely no interest satoshi
was an inventor and adam back submitted
several patents a year until 2005 when
he suddenly stopped between 2007 and
2011 he also didn't write any academic
papers compared to before could all this
had happened because he was too busy
working on bitcoin and then there's
satoshi's actual writing satoshi used
british english and double space after
periods who else does the exact same
thing adam beck who is originally from
london
so adam back basically disappears from
social media when satoshi shows up and
doesn't come back until satoshi goes
dark and suddenly after years of not
showing any interest in bitcoin adam
joins the bitcoin community with his
first ever post on april 18 2013
except instead of acting like the newbie
he was supposed to be he immediately
starts telling people what to do and
that's not all both satoshi and adam's
early websites look almost identical and
they were both proficient in c plus plus
coding just like everyone else on the
list adam back strongly denied that he
was satoshi nakamoto
[Music]
suspect 5 craig wright
in 2015 both gizmodo and wire published
articles naming a new guy as the creator
of bitcoin an australian computer
scientist by the name of craig stephen
writes wired wrote that craig wright had
either created bitcoin or was a good
enough scammer to make people believe
that he did that same day gizmodo
published a story claiming that craig
and another man named david clemen who
died in 2013 were behind the creation of
bitcoin the world went nuts especially
when craig wright first denied it and
then backtracked that claim and admitted
he was really satoshi later these claims
were supported by two bitcoin
heavyweights john matonis the
ex-director of the bitcoin foundation
and gavin andreessen another bitcoin
developer obviously people wanted proof
and all craig had to do was move some
coins from one of satoshi's wallets to
another but he didn't then people
started wondering if craig openly
admitted he was satoshi and he wasn't
trying to hide it anymore why didn't he
prove it by signing with one of
satoshi's keys
as the years went by people started
getting more and more skeptical then
things got weird the gizmodo article
named two people as the creator of
bitcoin craig wright and david clemen
who again died in 2013 while the brother
of david kliman recently sued craig for
his brother's share of the 50 billion
bitcoins the lawsuit goes through has
satoshi finally revealed himself after
all the court case couldn't continue if
the judge didn't actually think craig
could pay claim in the bitcoins he
apparently owed but then in may 2020
145 of the wallet addresses craig wright
was supposed to control posted this
message quote craig stephen wright is a
liar and a fraud he doesn't have the
keys used to send this message
we are all satoshi end quotes so it
seems like satoshi is still alive and
well but it definitely wasn't craig
wright's unless it was craig's decoy to
ruin the lawsuit whatever it was by
december 6 2021 craig wright wins the
lawsuit and does not have to pay david
clean his family over 25 billion dollars
[Music]
[Applause]
we are all satoshi
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
with no more viable satoshi suspects we
may have to face the reality that the
genius behind bitcoin may never be
unmasked before he died john mcafee said
that he was 99 sure who satoshi was a
group of 11 people who developed bitcoin
over five years
the
people think that satoshi
designed bitcoin nonsense it was a team
of 11 people
over a period of five years but he
refused to make that information public
in mcafee's opinion craig wright was
definitely involved but he wasn't the
only one and mcafee isn't alone a lot of
people agree bitcoin's code was too
complex to be written by one person
could it be that all five suspects that
we talked about in this video were part
of the 11 that made up satoshi is that
why the money hasn't been touched in
almost 12 years are there fail saves in
place to stop anyone from using the
bitcoins unless all 11 members agree but
if that's the case why were 640 bitcoins
transferred from one of the wallets
rumored to be satoshi's on july 12 2021
maybe peter thiel was right maybe it's
better for whoever satoshi is to stay
anonymous not just for the sake of
crypto but for the sake of their own
health
why is satoshi's identity unknown and
it's because well if we knew who it was
the government would arrest him maybe
some very bad things would happen to him
and i have a whole speculative history
and if you want more business
documentaries like this that are longer
and much darker to the point where i
can't release it to the public for fear
of being canceled click that join button
below or click the link below if you
don't see the join button you'll get
access to exclusive documentaries going
over how the world really works in all
its machiavellian glory that they will
never teach you in business school and
most of these documentaries will
probably get the monetized if i
published it to the public and rumor has
it this month's private documentary is
gonna be on everyone's favorite
government mind control program mk ultra
that full disclosure is probably gonna
get delayed because my posting schedule
is packed this holiday season and the
one after that is probably gonna be a
very juicy one on our friend efree
jepsteen we already have one out on
monsanto the company that owns the
world's food supply that you can watch
right now when you join and the best
part is that unlike business school
joining this isn't gonna bury you in
debts because you get all this hidden
knowledge for just five dollars a month
and i will personally refund you if you
don't think it's worth it if you email
me so sign up today by clicking that
join button below
[Music]
[Music]
you